I'm on to Libra and you are here for the
marvels of vengers exciting I am so
excited you know what I'm gonna get
straight to it because this is a big
cast first up we are going to bring out
some of the creative minds behind
Marvel's Avengers can we come to this
can we get to the stage Sean asked I
creative director and writer of Marvel's
Avengers VP and creative director Bible
games bill husband but now the Marvel
Comics artist Mark Brooks and next up
we're gonna start bringing some of the
cast out performance actor Ironman
marvel's avengers nolan north the mighty
thor odin's son Travis Willingham
[Music]
[Applause]
natasha romanoff the Black Widow Laura
Bailey
[Applause]
[Music]
Steve Rogers Captain America Jeff shiner
[Music]
[Applause]
the performance actor plays Bruce Banner
Troy Baker
that's a lovely chapeau you have there
sir and last but certainly not least the
new kid on the block who plays Kamala
Khan and Marvel's Avengers
Sandra Sardar all right you're all
assembled please have a seat
so we got a couple of questions you have
some mics in front of you oh I can share
mic with you Sean refreshments fine I
got you I got you
so we've revealed a couple things we've
showed a couple of amazing trailers
we've got new information this is such
an incredible cast so for everyone there
have been days weeks hours months that
have gone into this game and now it is
it is on its way out of the door what
has been your favorite moment working on
the game and why this one right now this
moment this moment right now this is the
one boom come on that was soft balled up
to you guys anybody else yeah I think my
favorite was during the performance
captured as Iron Man or as as Thor when
we hate in the middle of the scene we
had to take off and Iron Man would do
this and Thor would do that and then
we'd have to stay like that
well they finished the scene and just
that looking that ridiculous in front of
everyone
yeah cuz you guys why the character does
we get to start to fly and I haven't
perfected it yet
keep working hard I believe in you thank
you I do I would add on to that being
given a meal near to actually hold on
stage somebody would then come in
between takes and be like I'll take that
from me I'm like the hell you will I
think my favorite was any time we got to
as a team I know I just snagged one any
time as a team we got to like stand
battle ready it just made you feel like
an Avenger in that pose yeah and then
you look around and realize how dorky we
all are and it just felt really good I
think it was that same moment for me was
like day one and just like looking
around and seeing like Travis got the
hammer
Tony's doing the you know Troy's pushing
his glasses and I'm just like this is a
really happening like this is a thing it
was pretty awesome what about you Sandra
oh man I know I mentioned this to you
yesterday Anjali but my first day was
insane I had no idea what to expect
yes I'm the new kid on the block I ain't
never been on no mocap stage before and
meeting all these guys was insane my
first ever seen was with travis
willingham super super tall and I'm
super super not and like our first ever
seen my first ever seen on stage was the
one where he's like what's your name and
I'm like I don't know I forgot come I
have one I should I should use it so I I
have a moment oh I am you know it is
related to today because through this
whole process for months and months when
all we would get together when when the
story was being written
we were so influenced by the Marvel
Comics throughout the decades and we
would sit and we talk about it during
lunch and we'd bring comics to set and
we'd nerd out about our favorite issues
so now to see it all come full circle
and to see one of Marvel's greatest
artists Mark Brooks draw everyone on the
print that you're gonna get to see it
all comfort through inspired by the
comics given new life in the game to now
become full circle to be drawn again and
to be here in New York City the home and
the birthplace of Marvel Comics to
celebrate it with all the true believers
it doesn't get more magical than that
the perfect segue to talk about the
lithograph and it's amazing poster that
folks are gonna get today mark like
talked talked about the inspiration the
talk about the piece and like how it was
to draw the Avengers with Kamala Khan
well I've had the chance to draw of
interest for years you know thanks to
Marvel but getting to draw them in
iteration like this where there's so
much more detail there's so much more
design that goes into them
and being able to go online and watch
you know these guys do their thing
seeing them move bring some more to life
to me so I can put more love into the
piece is there anything that you
particularly thought just had to be in
this piece to make it the perfect piece
for this game I for me it just comes
down to I think that every character has
to look iconic so I was trying to
capture everybody and they're like that
they're they're prime you know a prime
moment but you have to do it in such a
way that they're all they all make sense
standing there together and hopefully I
did all right with that you did it's
it's a beautiful piece so for Bill and
Shawn what has been the most exciting
for you about bringing this original
story to life in this game for me it's
working with such a talented cast I mean
I don't know how you I mean I still
can't get over the privilege I have to
just stand amongst these giants stand
amongst you know Marvel and get this
opportunity to bring something like this
to life it's still mind-blowing for me
so for me that's one of the greatest
moments this is my moment by the way
right now well just seeing this lineup
and being part of it is awesome it was a
really treat the way Shawn really
assembled pun intended this crew they're
all off stars when it comes to
performing in games and they are truly
the Avengers of what they do
to see them come together but more
importantly to be able to it was so cool
to see them performing but then it was
really fun just to sit with them during
lunch breaks and just get to know them
as people and talk about who they are
and their experience with marvel growing
up and I was I really appreciated the
respect and the thought and the emotion
and the passion that they brought to
these characters they loved them just as
much as we do
and it's just a thrill and an honor to
stand alongside them as they assemble
your Avengers superfans oh I gotta give
it back Sean all right so last question
I am gonna challenge everyone on this
line to sum up in one word how they feel
about fans getting their hands on this
game one word you got one word Nolan
just won what was the question one word
to describe one word to describe how you
feel about fans getting their hands on
this game oh I'll kick it off yeah
somebody kick it off I'll kick it off I
got one impatient
drop them like I am and bigand about it
Laura excited that was my word - OH what
are you gonna do what are you gonna do
what are you waiting Indian soup is it
gazpacho soup sauces
gazpacho that's that's just spot you
know it's it's it's it's fantastic I saw
it almost come in your mouth with a
Fanta fantastic good yeah let's do this
let's do it
I don't want to weigh this guy's
checking his watch we gotta go he wants
it alright alright
hyped Heights I like it all right side
one Shawn you got the last word I'm
giving you the last word Shawn shot a
static boom you did it alright you know
what
what about marvelous
[Music]
leave it to Nolan all right so you know
I'd be marvellous if we go ahead and get
the fans up here and let them sign these
incredible pieces of artwork thank you
so much to the incredible cast and
creatives assembled here and we will let
that get started